ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on a
l'occasion d'avoir des champions du
monde comme partenaire d'entraînement
une dizaine de personnes dans les pas de
marie amélie le fur et arnaud assoumani
spécialiste du saut en longueur
tous deux étaient censés participer aux
jeux paralympiques de tokyo cet été le
report de l'évènement leur permet
d'assurer la promotion de paris 2024
l'idée c'est aussi de commencer à créer
du lien entre les athlètes et la
population pas mal d'athlètes sont
disponibles certains ne sont venus nous
voir et nous disaient qu'ils voulaient
faire des choses et dans ce cadre là on
a décidé de lancer dès cet été le club
paris 2024 pour que les athlètes et la
population puisse des moments
d'exception semble aujourd'hui on saute
comme les pros les champions
paralympiques ont pas mal de petites
astuces à partager avec ceux qui vont
les défier vos fesses ou venir en classe
et vos talents
en fait vous allez tomber entier et
après aux fesses de france
placez les jambes sorte le décor est
planté marie-amélie le fur ouvre les
hostilités le défi de commencer
[Musique]
ils viennent de toute la france pour
passer un bon moment sportif oui athlète
a toujours alors pas du tout je suis un
rugbyman
rien à voir donc moi c'est une bande
première je pense que la dernière fois
que j'en ai fait ça devait être au
collège en cours de sport donc voilà les
sensations bas c'est tout nouveau pour
moi mais c'est super agréable une super
ambiance
et puis on suit les conseils des des
champions des médaillés olympiques pour
s'améliorer et donner le meilleur de
nous-mêmes et on regarde voilà alors
faire profiter de nos conseils centraux
les aider non plus parce qu'à un moment
donné c était aussi une compétition mais
c'était juste génial en plus un temps
magnifique dans un superbe stade donc
très très bien on a été très menacé pas
forcément très performant dans play la
performance est attendue pour tokyo 2021
petit avantage du report des jeux la
possibilité enfin de prendre des
vacances
[Applaudissements]